In August 2017, Hurricane Harvey made landfall
in southeast Texas,
dumping more than a meter and a half of water
on the Houston area in 4 days.
It was the wettest hurricane in U.S. history,
causing extensive flooding and
125 billion dollars in damage.
So, after the storm, where did all of that water go?
The earth’s crust is surprisingly elastic --
it actually sinks under the immense weight
of new water -- like what was released by Harvey.
“So it kind of behaves like a mattress, in a way.
So if I was to sit down on a mattress,
I would depress that mattress
just because of my weight, right? And so
I can measure my own weight
based on how much I depress that mattress”
To track the water, researchers used GPS satellites
to measure fluctuations in elevation of the earth's crust
subsidence (down) and uplift (up).
“You could use that measuring stick
of the amount of depression
to try to figure out the weight of the water
The land around Houston sank as much as 20mm
during Hurricane Harvey, with a clear pattern
left in the crust that moved across the Gulf Coast
for seven days, consistent with Harvey’s position.
"The GPS not only to figure out where that water is
and how much occurred, but then
allows us to track how it dissipates,
how quickly it dissipates and how much dissipates.”
In the eight days following Harvey’s landfall,
30% of the stormwater was stored on land
as standing water,
60% of the stormwater immediately
drained into the ocean and Galveston Bay,
and the remaining 10% was lost to evaporation.
It took 5 full weeks for the water stored on land t
to dissipate through evaporation or groundwater runoff
“OK ,we can do it for Harvey, that’s easy,
because theres so much water, that weight
was so large, that depression in that mattress
is going to be really easy to see in the data.
So the next step is to say what about other
smaller, more frequent hurricanes with less water?
Could we apply the same type of analysis?”
The ability to track daily changes in the movement of
water during extreme events can help flood managers
better prepare for storms,
which will strike with increased frequency and ferocity
as global warming causes the
oceans temperatures to rise.
If we have any hope of weathering these future storms,
we must remember that, as my mom always says
“failure to plan is planning to fail”